Hello, everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome back
to Little Nightmares.
So we just escaped from the kitchen,
which means that chefs are going to be very mad at me,
and I don't know where I am. (You never know where you are Mark)
Now.
Is that a machine in the background?
[Disbelief]: Oh, is that the sun!?
[Unsure]: Good???
Or is that just a giant spotlight?
Okay.
Oh, no, that's the sun!
Maybe...
I don't wanna jump to any conclusions here because
I still-
We- we might either be on a boat or underwater
and I almost went right into the drink there.
O-kay.
How 'bout you grab onto that?
You know, any day now- There we go.
[Mutters]: Oh, man...
I just love this scenery in this game!
It's so expansive and detailed!
Like, just the water running down the...
Why-?
Okay.
Alright then,
OH, we're shaking now...
Ugh, what is that? (fog maybe?)
Okay...
Alright, in we go!
AAAAAH!
My EYES!!!
Hi!
We WERE on a boat!
We WERE!
We WAS were! (We also speak the English good!)
Oh my God!
Ooh!
But...
WHY though?!
Maybe I could just jump off into the ocean
and be done with all this, (Says the man who has a fear of said Ocean.)
but I suppose that's not the best way to go about this-
OH my GAHAhahad! (Mark has been amazed)
Oh my God, why?
But WHY though!?
WHY!?
Why am I go up here?!
Why am I do this!?
WHY!!??
O-h, wow.
LIKES,
Buh-
You know, I guess this is not too much of a surprise
All these BIG people need a BIG BOAT to carry them all-
But-
I hate to ask the question again, but also
Why???
You know,
For what purpose are they getting on this boat?
Is there like...
No land?
It seems to be...
A lot a' rain going on.
HI, how's it going!?
You're a BIG seagull. (That's what she said)
Er, a-
Again, maybe I'm a small person, but-
Ok, goodbye!
I'll just be going right back into the place that I tried to escape from.
Never coming back, okay.
Gotta be careful here.
I can't go drifting off the side.
Woah....
They're wearing.. masks??
Ughhh!
Ughhh! (Disgusted Markimoo)
Those don't look like any normal humohs (humans) that I've seen before.
They're a bit too.. rotund.
A bit bulbous...
A bit--
oddly misshapen and waddling.
Ugh..
So either they are humans or they're something else entirely.
Or they're humans have- that have been like..
morphed by some agent.
Some outside force that has created this alter-version of what humans could be.
And I don't know if that's any better than the idea that they're humans, but-
I dunno..
I'd kinda rather them just be aliens, and be done with it.
Although, I expect, in the long run
I don't expect my, uh, my questions to go answered, because-
Something tells me-
Oh...
Oh, you guys are gross!
[Chuckling in disgust and discomfort]
I mean- no offense, but, uh
You're just absolutely disgusting. Everything about you is repulsive to me.
Oh my God....
Oh, your waddling- such uniform fashion- is anyone gonna notice me?
Or are they just too- oh...
Hi...
Oh my God, it's that-
It's the, uh, porcelain doll lady from the very beginning of the game.
I guess we're going into her territory now.
Don't notice me!
But I don't know why you're not rotund like the rest of 'em.
Hi there.
Oh, you're just watchin', aren't ya? Ok, I'm gonna carry on in here!
Sorry I've been breaking your statues,
But obviously I haven't been breaking them all.
Oh my God.
I have so many questions!
Oh God- no, don't look up here
with your weird mask.
Oh my God, they all have masks.
Oh, maybe not all of them-
I don't think that one does. That guy is just a chubby-cheek, jolly old
whatever the hell you are. (Santa Claus)
[Noises of disgust]
Alright, SNOOPDY!
Alright.
SHOOBIDY-WOOPTY!
Ok, we made it! I think...
Lemme squeeze 'sqwowze' into here,
And hope that this gets a little better- Oh!
Ugh...
I don't like the shadows and I don't like the noises.
That's what I'm gonna say as soon as I enter this room here.
But y'know I'm gonna accept it- Ohh....
Hello?
Hello- OH!
So this is the result of those brothers' hard work.
I don't expect-
I don't expect I should just be bothered by any of this.
HEY!
[Voice cracking]: Are you enjoying your food?
It's probably made of my friends.
Ugh- why?
They're just all gluttonous.
Like, every one of them is so...
[Distracted by disturbing Santas, then TABLE FLIP!]
Well, okay, I was bothered
by everything that I saw and I didn't realize that I needed to be a little more cautious there. (The more you know)
I should be a little more--
a little more careful about my things and maybe-
maybe run this time- [Imitates sound enemy made]
You didn't see nothing.
Oh no! Oh no!
[The "Oh no" sounds from Mark]
AHHH!
OH GOD!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I don't want any o' that. (Or do you? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°) )
Woah! No, no, no.
You got plenty of food over there.
Why would you need me?
Ughhh!
Ugh, grandma, you have looked better.
Oh boy, hope no one knocks your stool out from under you. (SNEAK ATTACK!)
Maybe that's what I'm supposed to be doing here.
Uh.
I guess he's not chasing me anymore, so that's good!
I think I gotta climb up the stack of plates.
But something tells me that they're gonna be all- all over me
as soon as I do.
Oh no! Grandma!
No, no, grandma, don't do it!
Grandma!
It's not- it's not worth it! (Come here, my child!)
Oh my God!
Grandma, you're so floppy. ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Ah-ah-ah-ah-ah-oh no.
Grandma.
Ugh...
Ohh my God!
Grandma, you still after me or are you- have you given up the chase?
Oh boy.
Oh, good. I can dangle on this meat which is something I've always wanted to do. (Hehe...)
So what's the benefit of this?
Hugh, swing.
Swongo.
Oh, that didn't do me dick-doodley.
Can I push this?
Ah, I'm gonna knock your seat out from under your-
OH MY GOD! LOOK AT YOUR DROOPY FACE!
[Disgust]
LOOK AT YOUR DROOPY FACE!
NO!
[Disgusted noises]
This is the most disgusting episode yet.
Ughhh, oh no.
Ohhhhh God.
Oh, it's horrible. No, don't do it.
Oh my gawd!
[Laughing in disgust]: Oh, so f*cking gross!
Oh, why am I standing here making you guys stare at it longer?
I have no idea.
Okay, so I gotta get up there some how.
Oh, I guess this stool will just have to do.
Alright, okay as soon as I get up there, I got make a run for it some way.
HABITA-BOOSKY! Alright
Come on, come at me BRO! [Noises]
FRESH FOOD FOR YOU?!?
UGH! Get your fricking gross sasuage slurping-- Oh God [Laughs]
Give it up. (x2) Yeah! GIVE IT UP.
[Groans]: You guys don't try very hard.
You guys don't try very hard at pretty much anything,
so maybe it's not so much that they're here for a pleasure cruise.
It's they're here for a restaurant and-
Uh,
Somehow, they're getting all this food
and I don't know exactly HOW they're getting all this food.
I have a bad idea of how they're getting all this food but-
Uh...and all these mechanisms that are just rigged up for delivering more FOOD!
[Pitiful noises]
Alright but anyway,
anyway though...
Anyway, OK!
You guys having fun up there?
Oh yeah, you guys are having a good ol' time.
TRY NOT TO EAT YOUR HANDS WHILE YOU'RE SHOVELING THEM IN YOUR MOUTH!
Oh, fucking gross.
Fucking gross, bruh.
Alright, c'mon
I don't know where we're going.
[Starts glorious singing]
[Fucked up noises]
You s--- oh no...no, no
IT'S NOT WORTH IT, THOUGH!
But, WHY THOUGH!?
Ooooooh!
Nimbly-Bimbly, I went over Wimbly-Bimbly!
OOOOOOH!
I've reached the dessert area!
Good..
Don't mind me,
Smish smashing--something tells me you're gonna--
Man, no one--OH!
Oh...okay, alright then
["Get away from me" sounds]
NOT WORTH IT! You guys spend a lot of energy when you don't need to!
*SCREAMS*
Ohh-kay.
Ooooh no! Is you stuck?
I'm gonna bounce across your rotund back there, boyo.
Aaaaaaaaaaaand SHA-BOOSKY! BOINK!
Uh oh, that was less of a BOINK, and more of a DOINK!
Uuugh, okay, got it, nailed it though
I'm a champion.
Aaand SHWOOPTY INTO THE WINners circle.
Okay, alright.
Let's see if I can just get skibity-doo-da over here-
OH, I see a porcelain doll over there that I'm gonna-- BREEAA, hahahah, OH! Hi.
I thought I got away from you!
Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh!
GO in the doorWAY!
[Markiplier noise]
He'll never find me under the sink.
No, where did I go?
It's a mystery, truly, definitely don't check under here.
I guess it was uh.....
foolish of me to think they wouldn't be here because I seem to-- ooh..
Don't tell me he heard that..
Ok, I think it's safe.
Jesus.
Alright, so, oh my God.
No wonder they have so many toilets.
God, these people are just freakin'
[Chuckling]: gross.
Alright, so I gotta..
I gotta climb my way back up there and figure out a way--way to get to the door handle.
Can't go up there.
Alright, I gotta drag something over. Maybe, this jug..
Is this jug something grab-able?
Nah?
You know, I'ma gonna grab us some toilet paper and hope for the best.
Maybe that's gonna give me the boost I need.
If I set it, oh, so gently there..
Hop!
Hibbity-hop!
Hip-- this is a fruitless venture.
I don't know what I thought this was gonna work.
But okay.
Alright then. Can I climb up here?
Ah, no, I can't.
Alright, there's gotta be a way.
Ahh, oh no, but almost.
HEEUOPTY!
No, but almost.
Okay, maybe I can drag this?
No?
This?
Huh...
Ohhhh, it wants me to throw something in the mirror.
Ohhhh. That was a bit hard to understand.
[Window shatters]
Ohhhhhh--[Scared noises]
Well, that's a lot of back luck for me.
But okay! I get it, i get it!
I didn't know that this was a pathway through here, but okay, I get it...
Alright, so where to now?
Do I have my own private shittin' closet or something?
Do I just need to drag this over there?
Ooooh! I can climb up this thing!
Aaauuuhhh... okay.
I get it!
Okay, I think I'm understanding this a little bit better.
Oh.
Bonker-rooney.
Good thing they built this just for someone my size to be creep-crawling all the way through here...
Aaaand here we go!
I didn't have a little lantern in a while, don't know what the point of that was. Oh.
[Creepy chopping noises]
Alright, he's smish-smashing his way downtown there...
So i just gotta tip-toe along here and not fall like a GOOF!
Because that would kill me...
And then grap that porcelaine DOLL
Oauoauoau!
and smash it
as HARD as I can
over there!
He didn't hear a thing.
So, I'm gonna steal his ride
and go in the elevator,
because that's probably where I am supposed to be going
and I don't know why I need to release the black magical goop
from those porcelaine dolls
the evil, demon souls that are stuck within those
possessed beings.
And I don't know why it's necessary that I do that, but I...
I suppose it's good? Question mark? Uuuuhh...
[Mark inhales deeply]
Heeeyyy...
Hi...
Nice mask...
Alright buddy.
Can I give you a hug?
Ugh...
Hug
Aw. [laughs]
Well, I guess that's important.
Did you stick his hand...
in a bucket of water so that... he'd piss the bed?
Is that what you did?
Also...
Great practical joke
but also skirting with death a little bit there..
Alright I suppose that's all I needed to do.
Okay then..
Aww, little hug.
Alright.
Here we go!
I guess..
We'll go this way.
Ooh maybe I can climb-  nah
Alright
So, where am I now?
..and what am I walking into?!
AY! AY! OH! WHY?!
WHY ARE YOU ALL IN A PILE IN THERE!?
Did you just come out of an orgy??
OH MY GOD!
I'm sorry I disturbed all of you!
How did you know I was here?
Oh, that's not comforting at all.
Oh, that's the opposite of good.
OH MY GOD! There is no need!
Why am I this delicious to you??
Why are you freaks so intent on eating me?!
Oh boy. oh boy. oh b- OH MY GOD!
Okay, that's- that's normal.
I'm gonna assume that's perfectly normal.
EUUGH!
HII-YA!
Okay.
HURGH- GEEEGH!
GUEEGH
NOOOOO!
OH MY GOD! Your face- No! Your slurpy mouth!
Oh my god, it's Sausage Lady!!
Oh, that guy's too distracted by anything.
HHUUAAAAAAGH!!
Oh..
Ho-
Alrighty then..
Euugh..
I don't get it..
Why are they SO OBSESSED... with eating me?
I mean, I get it there are fables about giants that want to eat little children up.
..but..
EUHHH
blehh..
I don't get it..
They've got enough food.
Why do they need more?
and why-
(character coughing)
Ohhhh no.
I'M hungry now..
Oh no..
maybe this is kind of giving in a clue why I'm so hungry..
ALL the time.
Ohhhhh..
EUUUGHHH
Me hungry!
Me BIG hungry!
Put.. food in mouth!
I almost said, "put meat in mouth!"
I guess that's just the same as they're doing. but..
euuhh
(spoopy noise)
ooohh boy..
Is this why I'm starving so much. Is it because I don-
ohhhh!
You gonna be nice?
You gonna be nice?!
OH! You're nice!
Lemme slurp on that.
Lemme slurp on that a little bit..
Oh. You're SO nice.
You're so nice.
I'll take that.
Yeah, I'll-I'll take it I mean-
WOAH!
No- NOOO!!!
[Mark is shocked]
WHA- I GAVE YOU HUUUUGS!!
WH- I DIDN'T DO THAT!
[Mark is still shocked]
But I didn't do that!!
Is it because I didn't give him enough huuuuuuuugs??
[Mark sighs]
Well, I didn't expect this episode to be in the middle of a disgusting adventure..
..and then be EMOTIONALLY DEVASTATED!
I get being haaaangry (hungry)..
But this is ju- this is..
..ridiculous.
Can I munch on this?!
No?
I gave you guys.. hugs..
Awww..
I feel awful!
I FEEL AWFUL!
I'm no better than THEM!
Maybe that's the difference..
Maybe they're just giving into their hunger..
.. and there's some-
..hello.
Hi, can you-you give me some answers?
HEEY WAAIIIT!
LADY!!
Ugh...
Alright I guess..
Grab this and throw it at the button.
ugh
I don't know..
if that would have.. changed if I had given them more hugs!
I didn't know I needed to hug them all!
I would have GLADLY given them hugs.
I'm gonna hide, because i have a funny feeling something dark and demonic is gonna come out of there
uh-oh
oooh
The answer was... not quite.
Then why would I be able to go up here?
heuh
Alrighty then.. I'm gonna trust this
I guess.
Not much left to trust in this world
..especially not me considering I just ate someone..
..that was GONNA GIVE ME FOOOODDD!
I didn't choose that!
huuughh..
.. i feel bad..
woah.
Okay, you guys didn't say a god damn thing about
having
mmmmmmmmaaaaniquins..
Because if YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE HAVING
MMMMMMMMMMMMAAAANIQUINS
I'm gonna be having a prrroooblem..
EUGH..
EUUGGHH
I don't liiiiike this very much
I don't like it.. AT ALL, actually..
(spoopy vocalizing)
I don't know what that's all about but i th-
(more spoopy vocalizing)
I think it's bad..
Sooo.. here's the bets..
I go in there..
..and it's a talking mannequin
Number one.
Number TWO:
It's something even scarier than all the other creatures that wanna eat me up, outside..
OR
It's a nice lady
who's gonna give me lots of help and reward me for eating one of my own..
(spoopy vocalizing gets louder)
eugh..
(still vocalizing)
(Mark attempting to imitate her vocalizing loudly)
I can do that too, you know..
(still vocalizing..)
HI! Were you so ugly you br-AYYYYYYAYAY
OHH I DIDN'T MEAN TO
Well that was the WRONG solution!
I dunno why I did THAT..
well!
I suppose we discovered what we're supposed to be doing here.
..is uh..
She's bad too!
..and she has magic..
Which, I suppose, is even worse
so uh..
Am I supposed to creep or something?
(you know, she isnt a bad singer... not gonna lie..)
(it's just the music she is vocalizing is spooOO00oopyyy)
((spoopy vocalizing still happening))
I'm only moving when she's singing..
(still vocalizing..)
uugh ..ok....
..ok...
Ah! She's got a nice picture up there of her.
and the ony place.. with all the eyeballs and-ooookay.
I guess.. alright.. okay..
Who's the little girl on the wall?
I don't know!
Who's the person in the yellow raincoat back there... covered up by the drape
ohh..
You guys seeing what i'm seeing there?
You guys seeing what I'm seeing?
Ya.
Striking resemblance, it is indeed.
So.. why though
UH but
WHYYY THO??
Okay, so there's an answer
or there's a secret here.
So what I'm gonna do..
I think i need to break this.
SSSMOOSH.
(vocalizing stops abruptly)
You didn't hear..NOTHING!
This is a bad HIDING SPOT
OH BOY, YOU'RE GONNA FIND ME
HHHUUUAAAAAAHHH
(unsettling silence)
MAYBE SCREAMing wasn't the best option..
okay..
I guess maybe she's NOT gonna come kill me?
Which would be an AMAZING development in this adventure
but okay..
I'm still gonna take the sneak snonky route..
I'm gonna put on my squeaking shoes
or my sneaking shoes
and squeak the frick outa here..
So why are all the paintings
of this little girl
in a yellow dress.. covered up?
That is the question..
OOOOOH and she's
GONE.
greeeeeaaaatt